it's cool that we learned how to use the
console to manipulate other web pages
but of course we need to start making
our own it's easy to open up the page
I'm going to get rid of this hello world
here and all you have to do is open up
index.html in the browser of your choice
like we have here and refresh the page
and you'll see a very exciting blank
page let's talk about how we're gonna
write something here on this page it's
not too hard we can use jQuery x' dot
append function to add HTML to an
element on the page and if the element
already has some HTML content a pen will
add the new HTML to the end of the old
content yeah I've got resume builder
jeaious open here for our website we
want to append HTML to the pages header
we'll start with this jQuery selector
for header the pound sign tells us that
we're looking for an element with the ID
of header so in our HTML we see this div
with ID equals header this selector
grabs this tag let's give our students
the chance to try it out